nan
[music]
Thank you
Leave this to me and go ahead
It's a windmill now Don't be the enemy of the number of bars
And if Sakuyo wasn't by my side, it would have been posted
Don't worry about your ability, but there's a fence, but Sakiko,
you became a magical girl in order to get ahead,
right? To protect 23, right?
It's
blooming
Haa It
's okay
I'm a handmade doll I put all my heart into
each 4 dice
I like it
And on the right hand side is my quote It's
always good
Just now Doi No
matter how far apart
we are Together
Up until now and from now on
Ah ah ah
Don't worry
Until I live a life full of love and love
I won't collapse
That
's because I remember who I became a magical girl
I also
want to fight for the person I love I want to protect it I
'll go
Sakuyo
Even if you say that, if you say that, you
're a maiden in love who thinks you'll die right?
I dare to throw this away Yes, you
can go beyond these photos and attack me
But the
mini me
will get stronger